[Music]
foreign you are watching The Press
preview a first look at what's on the
front pages as they arrive it's time to
see what's making the headlines with a
former conservative MP and CEO of the
charity business in the community Mary
McLeod and journalist and author Rachel
shabby they'll be with us from now right
up until just before midnight so let's
see what's on some of those front pages
for you now
the partygate report handed down today
is dominating the front pages beginning
with the mail which quotes Boris Johnson
who denies misleading Parliament over
lockdown parties
Boris Johnson's comeback in Peril says
the eye after text messages revealed in
today's report
the guardian says there's fresh evidence
that Mr Johnson misled MPS
while the times says MPS could punish
Boris Johnson over the Gatherings
he knew writes the mirror about lockdown
parties in number 10.
the express follows suit with the party
gate probe
the star refers to the former PM as a
fibber by comparing him to Pinocchio
Matt Hancock leads the telegraph's
coverage tomorrow with a battle over
covid restrictions between he and Rishi
sunak
arms snub to City blamed on FCA raised
the front of the financial times as it
explores reasons why the stock has
behaved in that manner
and reminder that by scanning the QR
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us
and we are joined tonight by former
conservative MP and advisor to the Royal
household who's now chief executive of
the charity business in the community
Barry MacLeod and journalist and author
Rachel shabby thank you both good to see
you let's start with the I newspaper and
their headline Boris comeback in Peril
after damning texts from own staff
Rachel you take us into this story
sure so the eye and obviously a lot of
other papers are covering this story and
um the eye gives us a rundown of what
the revelations are so this is an
interim report from the Privileges
committee
um it's basically indicating its areas
of interest and it's doing that ahead of
calling up Witnesses including Boris
Johnson himself later this month and so
what it's saying is that it would have
been obvious quote to Boris Johnson that
the events that he attended at number 10
were in fact would in fact have been
illegal under the uh lockdown rules and
social social distancing rules at the
time
um there's also evidence emerging that
his own staff
and particularly his com staff were
frustrated with this were frustrated
with what this would look like uh were
it to be leaked which obviously it was
and also that he Boris Johnson then
prime minister knew about various
there'd be these after work drinks
things on Fridays in number 10 and Boris
not only knew that these were taking
place but in fact occasionally attended
them so those are the main
um Revelations from this
um privileges committee that have
emerged today yes and Mary according to
the eye senior numbers 10 staff thought
there was a great gaping hole in his
denials about illegal lockdown parties
yes and we don't know how many staff
this these uh come from but
um there are certainly some that are
there and have been seen so therefore
that he needs to answer to that and
what's interesting about the I
um headline is that it sort of assumes
that Boris Johnson come back or when it
says that that has come back is in Peril
uh because that's a whole other story
though for another day but
um but yes I mean this is a a
development in a story that just it
doesn't seem to to go away and what's
frustrating it just needs to be resolved
and hopefully that will be done really
quickly
um a once he goes in front of them but
it's just
um you know Boris Johnson will will sort
of say very strongly that he hasn't
misled MPS and and it will be up to the
the committee to to make a judgment on
that and it and it's you know he he
thinks the report will clear him he is
saying that and very strongly but
um but yeah he's got to convince you
know quite a lot of people and of course
I'll then go to if it's found that he
has
um a misled Parliament anyway that of
course goes to to Parliament as well to
an MPS to
um take a view on so it's
um
this is this is a point where he you
know he is definitely trying to probably
fight for survival on this and and they
will have to make a judgment column
whether they think he really believed at
the time
um that he was breaking any rules let's
move on to the express
um also same story
um he's saying that the the party gate
probe this is Boris Johnson this is his
quote that it's a a cynical stitch up
but this was
um an investigation that that he
actually praised previously though
wasn't it Rachel
yeah I mean just to put into context
this claim that he didn't know and that
he wasn't lying
um you know the times has got a quote
from what one went from the committee
where one witness told Johnson at a
crowded event at number 10 in November
2020 when obviously those rules were in
place one witness actually said to
Johnson that this was quote probably the
most unsocially distanced gathering in
the UK so he's actually being told that
by someone he's standing next to at one
of these illegal events so it's again
another sort of strand of how far this
is stretching the imagination that he
didn't know
um he cynically accusing
um Sue grave being politically motivated
I have to say it does not help in my
view that labor has
um plans to point her Chief of Staff
because it does
essentially opened the door to these
kinds of accusations I'm not saying the
accusations are true at all I'm just
saying that it was unwise to put it
mildly for labor to open this door but
actually what we're saying with a lot of
these fronts is just how politically
motivated
uh you know the tone of these front
pages are so we've got the mirror saying
well he lied
um and we've got the Daily Mail sort of
saying well he'll be fine he was
Vindicated which are obviously very very
different lines to take
yes the the express also saying and
quoting in quote marks Vindicated which
is uh what Boris Johnson saying that he
has been by the report and this is
before he um gives evidence to
Parliament Mary
yes and then it says there on the on the
front page
um of the express you know it's that a
it's that whole thing around did he
knowingly
um mislead mislead Parliament and they
will make it they will judge that
um but it's I agree about this who gray
appointment and being good if they'd
held off a few weeks perhaps to to to
make that announcement as part of this
because it looks like it's muddying the
water I mean she's a senior civil
servant with years of experience
um so but it's it just creates an
additional angle on on this story that's
that sort of need not needed it right
now but it's you know this this
hopefully will get resolved very very
quickly but it's uh I mean boros will
continue to fight
um on on what he thinks is is right and
uh and the thing is I mean there are
photographs there that
um show certainly number 10 staff having
having a drink
um and therefore he's really got to
prove that he knowingly didn't lie about
it him that he didn't feel at the time
they were breaking any rules so yeah
she's got work to do in the next two
weeks yes and as you say that the
photographs there um that we hadn't
previously seen but still he's insisting
that there's no evidence that he misled
MPS Rachel
foreign
but there are pictures there are actual
pictures and I just think the evidence
is just becoming more and more it's like
an avalanche now and as this you know
I'm just going to repeat what this
privileges committee has said that it
would have been obvious quote for him
that those
um Gatherings would have been illegal I
think the idea that would have been
obvious to him does suggest that he knew
and misled
um and when we look at the the times
it's it's suggesting that
um his own MPS are increasingly
disgruntled with this and are you know
trying to look at ways that potentially
that this might have political
consequences for him
um potentially being suspended for the
party
um potentially having to
um stand for a by-election in his seat
in Uxbridge if he gets
um if he gets deselected by his own
local constituency party but it is
interesting that the some of the
conservatives are trying to do that I
mean obviously it would be a a clear
dividing line
um for sunac to face down
um
team Boris inside the conservatives but
it also speaks to the conservatives
incredible capacity to constantly
reinvent themselves or want to appear to
by ditching their former leader and then
saying well it was nothing to do with us
it's a brand new party now as though
they didn't all serve under him and
agree with him at the time but the times
I Throw It Forward Mary as in what could
happen to Boris Johnson and his uh
potentially his political career could
be ended
yes no absolutely and I think it's
that's why you know he will absolutely
be fighting for to get his side
um of the story and to prove that and
that and hopefully for him
um that it will vindicate him but you
know I mean this is this continues to be
a very sensitive story generally because
this whole whole public perception is
just not good and I think what's
happening with membership Parliament is
that they're just getting frustrated
that this story is still out there
because it doesn't do
um his party any good it doesn't do
um a politicians and politics and
government and Parliament any good and
because lots of people during covert had
just such you know horrific things to
deal with and my mother died during the
pandemic but thankfully I was allowed
into hospital for the last two days to
see her but lots of people weren't and
and had to suffer a real hardship and
difficulties and and didn't get anywhere
near their loved ones during during that
time so you know it's just it's hugely
sensitive across the country this whole
story but I think that MPS will be
getting really frustrated that it's
still been talked about and that they
just want an end to it whatever however
it's resolved
and you were mentioning Rachel that um
Rishi sunac will will have to uh face up
to this as well because the Privileges
committee eventual verdict will have to
be approved by the the House of Commons
is that right
yeah and I think
um you know I think Mary raises a really
important point that you know this can
turn into a
he said she said they said whatever you
know gossipy Lobby journalists doing The
Insider parliamentary track but actually
there's there were very real
consequences at that time
um there are lots of people up and down
this country who are still hurting who
are still grieving who is still mourning
um who are still coping with all kinds
of issues around uh the sacrifices that
people needed to be needed to make
around that time and so that's the
reason why this is such a burning issue
it's not about you know sunx management
or or whatever of the party it's not
about Boris Johnson's teaching a
comeback or not it's the fact that lots
of people you know put up with such a
lot during that time and it looked like
the people who are in charge of making
those rules were breaking them so of
course this is going to go on until it
is resolved until we we know one way or
the other indeed Rachel and Mary before
the moment thank you we are going to
take a break much more coming up we'll
continue the Press preview about this
drawing on page two of the express it's
headline 999 strikes called off the
fresh pay talks stay with us
[Music]
welcome back you are watching The Press
preview still with me former
conservative MP and CEO of the charity
business in the community Mary McLeod
and journalist and author Rachel shabby
welcome back to both of you let's have a
look at the um
Telegraph and we're looking at the Matt
Hancock story and the revelations from
the various WhatsApp messages and what
they revealed today another day from
what the telegrapher calling their
lockdown files and we read that uh Rishi
sunak and Matt Hancock were um locking
horns over the pandemic and the handling
in terms of lockdown Mary
oh
we've lost Mary's sound sorry
I'm I'm back again
um yes this is in essence the the
lockdown files and
um and Matt Hancock trying to get him
Simon cases at the cabinet secretary
um to a in the engine of what seems to
be in sort of rise over covered
restrictions
um and just on what those extent of
those lockdown measured and those
restrictions
um should be and a and and just the and
I guess the frustrations that that went
that went with that but the WhatsApp
messages of course and published you get
a sense a sense of that as part of it
um and I guess um I guess there's
definitely a Lessons Learned on on what
you put in a WhatsApp message
um for anyone I think
um and and being able to see some of
this that's now come to now come to
light and so um and of course that
you there's any questions for Simon
Keith and what his his role in this as
well but
um but yeah it just goes to the
complexities off of covert and I mean
there's part of this that you know I I
sort of take into account the fact that
it was such a difficult time for any for
anyone trying to make decisions at this
point in time
um and I think all governments around
the world were
um is struggling with it to some extent
because it was something new and
therefore a it was a very stressful
intense time so to some extent I'm not
surprised about some of um these things
but but they're now of course coming to
light about the um how how awkward some
of those exchanges yes um actually there
is there is some of the detail that's
pointing towards the the Rivalry that
that was in cabinet um Rachel and
there's a section here saying that uh
both uh Mr Hancock and um Richie sunac
had Ambitions for higher office and
messages that have been seen by the
telegraph suggest the level of paranoia
from Mr Hancock of his colleagues access
to Boris Johnson
yeah I think you're right that these
these messages do point to that kind of
rivalry and the tensions between them
but I think what this speaks to if we
can just pan wider for a second is the
trouble with these being leaked to a
newspaper that has such a clear agenda
now this is an anti-lockdown newspaper
it's called this
um investigation the lockdown file so it
clearly has an agenda and we're starting
to see that agenda emerge when we look
at this particular story because what
they're trying to say is that actually
um Hancock was paranoid
um British sooner then Treasury and um
Alex Sharma then business secretary
um were both trying to get him not to
impose
um various lockdown measures that he
wanted to impose so you can see clearly
there that there actually is an agenda
here to portray uh hancockers
overzealous if you like on on the
lockdown and it's interesting that they
choose to lead with this story and not
another story in their inside Pages
where they're talking about how Hancock
is ridiculing Richard sunax he eat out
to help out scheme which you'll remember
ran as a kind of you know discount
incentive for people to go and eat out
in restaurants and cafes
um
Hancock called this
eat out to help spread the virus about
as a joke and then later said no
actually we've got evidence quite clear
evidence that this scheme is helping to
spread the virus that seems to me much
more important and much more
consequential than a kind of rivalry
political spat that is going on between
Hancock and his political peers okay
Mary just uh update us on the ambulance
uh workers strikes
yes
um the what's really sort of good news
is about the strikes planned by
ambulance workers for next week have
been suspended and really good news on
that
um because you know I must you know they
wouldn't have wanted to go on strike it
is a last resort
um but they have ministers who are going
to discuss
um a P with them
um and that they are looking also about
improving paramedics terms and
conditions
Mary but just to say that's GMB and
Unison but uh United are still taking
strike action thank you so much both for
taking us through the papers we'll see
you in the next hour